[MUSIC PLAYING]
NATHAN BARNES: My
name is Nathan.
I just want to thank
everyone for showing up
and your patience today.
We got this awesome
event going on today.
It was my pleasure and honor to
introduce Jessica Lea Mayfield.
She had time on her tour
to come stop by and talk
with us for a little bit, so
we can learn about her past
and what kind of
brought her here today.
And we'll end with a
little set hopefully
with some beautiful songs--
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Sure.
NATHAN BARNES: --and
maybe some Q&A as we go.
But yeah, hello.
How are you doing today?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Good.
[APPLAUSE]
Yay.
Hi, Nathan.
So yeah, I am doing well.
Thanks for having me here.
Are we under, like,
a giant guitar hole?
NATHAN BARNES: I think so, yeah.
AUDIENCE: A 10-string guitar.
NATHAN BARNES: We're
hoping that the finale will
be somehow incorporated
into that guitar,
but we'll get there.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Interesting.
NATHAN BARNES: We'll get there.
Yeah.
Excellent.
Well, you have such
a long kind of career
even though you're kind of
like-- it's a short career.
Like, you started in a
family band as a child.
That seems kind of like a
very interesting opportunity
and a way to kind of adapt
and guide your musical career.
Would you mind telling us
a little bit about that?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Oh, OK.
Well, yeah.
I've been doing this
for a really long time.
So I started doing
music with my parents
when I was eight
years old, and we
lived on an old
tour bus that was
owned by a bunch of popular
bluegrass and country musicians
at one point-- and
basically just travel around
like hippies.
So I've been touring since
I can remember basically.
NATHAN BARNES: That's amazing.
I could only imagine just kind
of being on the road, one,
but that's with
the family-- two,
dynamic-- like, that could
be a very interesting kind
of relationship to kind
of roll with-- bond with,
and then also just kind of
takes that musical experience
as a positive and
keep moving with it.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: I think
it just kind of-- it definitely
made--
really, it just kind of made
everyone feel like there
weren't really family roles.
It was just like, OK, we're
all on the same level here
doing the same thing sort of.
We're all just traveling
around trying to make money,
so it's just really interesting
to feel like you were
on a team with your relatives.
NATHAN BARNES: Awesome.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: OK,
so you guys take-- you
and your brother take that
street corner, and your mom
and I will go over here.
And let's all play for tips, and
come back, and see what we got.
And it's interesting--
definitely an interesting way.
NATHAN BARNES: Was there
like a favorite song or kind
of a go-to track that
you guys had together,
or maybe it was like the one
you guys enjoyed doing the most?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Usually
we pick kind of one song,
but whatever songs seem to be--
I'm trying to
remember right now.
A lot of times it would
be requests of people
would want to hear stuff
like "Amazing Grace."
I'd be like, OK.
I was just, like, a little girl.
I'm like, whatever.
NATHAN BARNES: Awesome, awesome.
Well, you know, obviously,
your musical career
did not end there.
It kept moving.
And then 2006 about,
if my memory serves,
that's when "White
Lies" came out.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Mhm, yeah.
NATHAN BARNES: That was kind
of when I was first introduced
to you and your music while
you were touring with the Avett
Brothers, and that was a
beautiful summer of '07.
I was very happy
to meet you there,
but as kind of the
legend goes, that
was the album that kind of got
a particular artist's attention.
And if I have it
right, the gentleman
from Black Keys, Dan Auerbach--
and then what happened?
What snowballed from there?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Well,
he's from Akron, Ohio,
and I'm from Kent, Ohio.
But when I had recorded that
album at home in a bedroom,
it ended up getting over to him
somehow, and then from there
we started just meeting
up a couple of times
a week and recording,
not really knowing
what it was going to be.
And then I ended up making
my first record with him,
and then I made my second
record with him as well.
NATHAN BARNES: How was that?
Because at that time you
could have been a teenager
one would guess.
And like, that
could be a very kind
of unique kind of guiding
experience for a young artist
to meet someone kind
of that's a big name.
Like, an adult coming
to you and wanting
to produce and push your music,
that seems pretty magical.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Oh, yeah.
It was definitely
interesting to kind of--
I had a lot of
friends at the time,
who knew who they were--
who the Black Keys were.
And I was just kind of--
I got hip to it around
the time that I met him,
and that was around the
time that they were really
starting to get more popular.
So I thought, you know, OK,
I'll go hang out with this guy,
I guess, and work in his
studio, and it'll be whatever.
But it definitely
ended up you know--
still to this day, I
meet a lot of people
who, the first
album they heard is
the first one that
I did with Dan, so I
think that there's still--
people are going
back and finding out
about me through an album
that came out over 10 years
ago almost.
NATHAN BARNES: That's crazy.
I kind of did the reverse.
Like, I had heard
that you were doing
backup vocals on some kind
of sloppy, jammy blues band.
I was like, oh, I
should check it out.
And then that's
when I find that you
did the backup vocals
for "Things Ain't
Like They Used To Be," right?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Mhm, yeah.
NATHAN BARNES: And
that was kind of--
I had the reverse kind of
interaction with the Black Keys
like, oh, who is
she playing with?
Oh, OK.
Right on, this is sweet.
These guys are good.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Yeah.
NATHAN BARNES: Awesome.
Well then, from there we'll--
so the next album
you came out with--
"With Blasphemy, So Heartfelt"--
that was kind of like
your first major produced album
that you and your brother kind
of self-released, produced.
How was that kind
of new experience
from family jam band, to
now stuff on your own,
to kind of like this
more potentially dynamic
for a specific process?
JESSICA LEA
MAYFIELD: It's funny.
"With Blasphemy" was
kind of pieced together
over a period of time where
Dan had this rental space,
and he would get in
different gear and kind
of call me over to guinea
pig and try stuff out.
And then stuff from that became
that album, which is funny,
because then by the time I
did my next album with him,
it was real studio vibes.
But that first thing was
just kind of like, all right,
one of us has to reach over and
turn this machine on and then
get--
whoever's closer to it and who
isn't starting the song first.
It was very still kind of--
I feel like "With
Blasphemy" still
has those bedroomy
vibes of just like, hey,
we're using nicer
stuff, but it's just
like a very small
group of people.
But I can't even
really say a group.
NATHAN BARNES:
Was there any kind
of intimidation level with it?
Like, obviously, you've been
around music and performers
as a young kid.
So was is just like
another day at the office,
or was there kind of like on
moment involved in it at all?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
I mean, not really.
I don't get-- it's interesting.
I don't really get too
nervous around people.
NATHAN BARNES: Good for you.
It's a great power.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
--more like single people
not like a large
group of people maybe.
I don't know.
That sounds bad.
NATHAN BARNES: Awesome, awesome.
Well, I kind of brought
the Avett Brothers earlier
and like definitely
seeing you guys tour.
Like, any time you
guys do a harmony,
it's the most
beautiful thing ever.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Thank you.
NATHAN BARNES: Love
Scottie so much.
And so, you guys have this
awesome Elliot Smith tribute
album.
That's just beautiful
and gorgeous,
and it's obvious that Elliott
Smith was a potential influence
around you.
But I'm kind of curious what
led you to this specific project
and also with Scott Avett.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: That
was with Seth actually.
NATHAN BARNES: Oh, sorry.
JESSICA LEA
MAYFIELD: No worries.
NATHAN BARNES: Pardon me.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: That's OK.
There were actually people
that would come to the show
and still think that it was
Scott, which I don't get.
I think people confuse
them just a little bit.
NATHAN BARNES: Pardon my nerves.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
No, it's OK.
Whatever.
I'm just kidding.
Seth and I realized that we were
both big Elliott Smith fans,
and that was just
something we would end up
talking about almost every time
we saw each other until one
point we were on tour together.
And we both walked
into the screen room,
and it had a piano.
And he started playing
an Elliott Smith song,
and I started singing it.
And from there,
we were like, OK,
we should do
something like this.
And we just kept
sending each other voice
memos of Elliot
Smith songs until we
had more than enough ideas.
NATHAN BARNES: That's very cool.
And it's a lovely album.
And I was always trying
to put my finger on a way
to kind of describe
it, and I kind of
stumbled upon a review
that of set it so well
to where it wasn't like you guys
trying to reinvent or change
the songs and make it your own.
It was more just kind of like an
honest homage to Elliott Smith,
and that just kind of put it
all into a wonderful nutshell
for me when I was like
thinking of that album--
how you guys put it together.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Well, thank you.
It was kind of
stressful, especially
as huge Elliott
Smith fans, I think
we understood that
you're attempting
to mess with something
that's pretty delicate.
And I had to put myself in the
shoes of if someone else did
that, would I be like,
what are you doing?
You can't sing
Elliot Smith songs.
Like, no, only he can do that.
You know, he's the best at that.
So there's definitely
that line to draw
of wanting to do a
good enough job to do
it justice without
making it too different
or ruining it somehow.
I think we just didn't
want to ruin it.
NATHAN BARNES: Well,
whatever level you found,
it was wonderful
and thank you for.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Oh, thank you.
NATHAN BARNES: The version of
"Fond Farewell for a Friend"
was just--
it gets me.
It's very beautiful.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Thank you.
NATHAN BARNES: Yeah.
What else do I have
to harass you with?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Any more compliments?
No, I'm just kidding.
[LAUGHTER]
NATHAN BARNES: Oh, that's
what the last page is.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
I like this.
NATHAN BARNES: I just
have a list of things
that I like about you,
so we'll get there.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Ooh.
NATHAN BARNES: Don't worry.
Yeah, yeah.
Well, we have your newest
album, "Sorry is Gone."
It's a very interesting
album for me.
It felt like there
was a lot more.
Like, it just seems there
is so much happening though,
but it flows really well.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Did you not like it?
[LAUGHTER]
NATHAN BARNES: No, I do like it.
But this is why
I'm bringing it up.
There's just this kind
of rawness within it.
Like, it's not it's scattered.
It flows for me, but it does
have a different depth for me.
And then when I saw the
title of "Sorry is Gone,"
I was wondering if that was kind
of a reflection of the steps
that you were trying to
kind of create or maybe
project with it.
Because it's such
a kind of simple--
it's saying so little
with just "Sorry is Gone,"
but it seems like there was kind
of a lot behind it potentially.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Well,
I mean, I think this album,
it came together
without me really
realizing if any theme
there was going to be.
And I realized that
a lot of the songs
were all working together
for the theme of being
not afraid to be
yourself, I guess,
which obviously sounds
cheesy and funny.
But it's I don't
know-- you shouldn't be
embarrassed to talk about them.
NATHAN BARNES: Yeah,
that's beautiful.
And I think that's kind
of this variation of sound
that kind of comes into
producing this album.
It kind of reflects
what you were just
saying of that
genuine self, which
I found was really awesome.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Thank you.
NATHAN BARNES: And I was
just curious about the title
and like maybe how
it played with it.
Sweet.
All right.
Well, I have some more kind
of just like silly questions
for you.
If we may, we can
lighten the mood
a little bit before we
hear some of your music.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Ask away.
NATHAN BARNES: So like, I
feel like there is always
someone at shows who
just kind of wants
to scream song requests at you,
so is there any in particular
that have stood out over the
years-- that kind of maybe
cracked a smile or maybe
even were, like, indulged?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Let's see.
I don't think I've ever had
anyone request something--
unless it's my song,
and they request it,
then I might play it.
But it's one thing, people
will go back with my songs,
and they'll go
really, really far to,
like, the very,
very first album.
NATHAN BARNES: "White Lies"?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Yeah, they'll
want to hear something that's
more than 10 years old that I
wrote when I was, like, 15.
And I'm thinking, I
don't remember that.
And this is like--
there was this one show
where I had played and then
came back up for the
encore, and we were all
getting ready to play
"Our Hearts are Wrong."
This drunk woman comes up,
and she goes, no, stop.
And she's like, you're
going to play this song.
And it was like some really
slow, weird, sad song
off of "White Lies."
And I'm like, no, this is
the last song of the night.
It has to be something fun.
And she got really
mad and stormed out.
So that's probably a
more interesting thing.
I think people get
really emotional
if I don't do what
they ask me to.
NATHAN BARNES: Well, you're
there for them, right?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Yeah.
I'm like, I'm sorry.
Like, I have a plan,
like a list of songs
to do that the band learned.
NATHAN BARNES: And I
promise this one wasn't
like a temperamental question.
I didn't bring it
up on the spot.
But I was wondering if--
over the years of touring,
I'm sure you kind of
come across a lot
of interesting,
to silly, to, like, comical
interactions or obstacles.
And I'm wondering if
you have maybe one that
comes to mind that brings
the biggest smiles or laughs
as you look back?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Obstacles that bring--
NATHAN BARNES: Silly things
like traveling every day,
on the road, cars--
there could be always
trouble out there, you know.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Oh,
there's always trouble
out there like booking a
hotel in the wrong city,
and then driving to the right
city, and realizing it later.
I'm trying to think of what kind
of goofy snafus that happen.
I don't know.
It's actually kind
of boring honestly.
It's just kind of like
sitting in a hotel eating.
NATHAN BARNES: That sounds nice.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
It's like eating in bed--
playing a rock
show, eating in bed.
Maybe if I'm lucky I can
lay in bed before the show
if I have time.
This is where it gets
really exciting--
basically just like eating,
and sleeping, and music--
NATHAN BARNES: The normal
things-- people things.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
--and driving.
NATHAN BARNES: Awesome.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Yeah.
NATHAN BARNES: Well, kind
of like on the same level--
is there, like, a group or
an artist that you've enjoyed
and that was kind of
touring or has been kind
of a special or fun experience?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Well, it's
funny you mentioned the Avett
Brothers.
I kind of look back on that--
that was some of the
first touring that I did.
It was with them and
with the Black Keys,
and I was really young.
And that was the
first time I ever
did any West Coast touring
was with the Avett Brothers,
so there was definitely
a lot of first-time tour
things with them that
I always think about.
That's fun, because
I'll go somewhere,
and I'll be like, oh, yeah.
I've been here a
million times now,
but I remember the
first time I came here.
NATHAN BARNES: Sweet, very cool.
And then how about like, what
do you listen to these days?
And if there is like--
if you were trying
to sit in a bed
and eat some food in a hotel
room, what do you put on?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: OK, well.
Let's see.
What do I put on?
I don't really watch much TV.
NATHAN BARNES: Or music-wise,
who do you listen to?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Music-wise, it's funny.
I don't really
branch out very much.
I keep to, like, the
same group of artists,
so it's always Elliott Smith,
Metallica, Soundgarden,
just all '90s--
NATHAN BARNES: '90s classics?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
--heavy, a lot of heavy music.
I've been trying to listen
to some books on tape,
but it's hard to stay awake.
So it's not a good thing
to do while driving,
but I still try
to do it anyways.
And then if you fall
asleep while you're
listening to it in bed, then
you don't retain any of it--
so still trying to figure
out books on tape--
NATHAN BARNES: It'll
be there for you.
They'll be waiting
for you, I promise.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
--and how that works.
NATHAN BARNES: Awesome.
Well, you know, I just
wanted to kind of spend
some time to share your past
and hear where you're coming.
And like, while
you're here today,
maybe now would be a good
time to treat everyone
with their patience with a few
tracks and then maybe a little
Q&A at the end, if
that's all right by you.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Sure.
NATHAN BARNES: Beautiful.
Well, I'm going to
recede from the stage.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Can
I have a sip of that water?
You're going to leave me?
NATHAN BARNES: I'll
sit here if you like.
Yeah, I can be the water.
[LAUGHTER]
Well, I'm going to sit
here and be the water boy.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: You're
welcome to sing along.
NATHAN BARNES: Oh, god.
I might on accident.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
There is a show tonight.
NATHAN BARNES: Oh, of course.
Pardon, I should
know about that.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Will you
be singing at the show tonight?
NATHAN BARNES: I will be
singing at the show tonight.
Tonight, at the
Independent, we'll
get to see a full set from the
lovely Jessica Lea Mayfield.
Tickets are still
probably available,
and if you have nothing to do,
you should come and join us.
[APPLAUSE]
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Here
is your practice for later.
[MUSIC - "SORRY IS GONE"]
[APPLAUSE]
Do you have any
requests, Nathan?
NATHAN BARNES: Oh, my goodness.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Oh, gosh.
NATHAN BARNES: Well,
if I go, I would
hate to say something too old.
But I've had "For Today"
stuck in my head for a minute.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Do
you want to hear that?
NATHAN BARNES: If you
would, I would not--
yeah?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: I
would do that for you.
NATHAN BARNES: Goodness.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: All right.
NATHAN BARNES: Yes, please.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: That is--
it's going back pretty
far, but for Nathan--
NATHAN BARNES: To the
beginning-- to the beginning.
Goodness.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Thank you, guys.
[MUSIC - "FOR TODAY"]
[APPLAUSE]
NATHAN BARNES: Thank you.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Thank you.
NATHAN BARNES: Thank you
for keeping that in my head
for the next week or two.
So what do you think you--
a little break for some Q&A?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Yeah,
you want to-- do you want to--
you want me to play more?
Do you have more questions?
NATHAN BARNES: I kind of
ran through my questions.
Maybe we can do a little
Q&A then some more songs?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Yeah, totally.
NATHAN BARNES: Beautiful.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Or I could play a song
while you ask me a question?
NATHAN BARNES:
Yeah, let's do that.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
OK, so just start asking.
I'll come up with something.
[PLAYS GUITAR]
NATHAN BARNES: There
is a microphone
in the back of the
room for those of us
who would like to ask
Jessica some questions--
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Oh, OK.
NATHAN BARNES: --and not watch
me awkwardly dance around
the stage.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Hello, Jessica.
Thank you for coming.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Wow, you sound great.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to
ask what do you find most
gratifying about your career?
Is it making music
and touring, or is it
putting an album out or
meeting super fans like Nathan?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Those are great points.
I think there's
something too about--
it could be-- it's
interesting to--
I really like the personal
process of writing songs,
and then I feel like the
process of sharing them almost
goes against what it is,
because it's definitely a really
private collection of feelings.
And then I go out and
share them with everyone,
so there is kind of those
two different aspects, which
I like to have the contrast.
AUDIENCE: Well, thank you.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Who do you
share them with first?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Ooh,
I'm kind of weird like that.
So if I'm going to work
on it with someone,
then I would play it for them.
Otherwise, if I'm just
working on something,
I might just play it at a
show and see what happens.
And I try it once, and if
I don't like it, then I'm--
just never play it again.
Otherwise, if I like
something about it,
then it might make its way
into something eventually.
AUDIENCE: Cool, thank you.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Yeah, rad.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Next.
No, I'm just kidding.
AUDIENCE: On a related subject,
we have a few groups here
for songwriters,
producers, and musicians.
And a topic that
frequently comes up
is the difficulties of
the songwriting process
is finishing what you start.
I'm wondering what you can share
with us about your own process
and, you know, the difficulties
in writing a song album.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: I
think that it's easier--
it's easy to realize
that something might not
be that great of an idea
if you're having a really
hard time finishing it.
So I think the
thing about that is
to make sure you
are excited enough
by the idea to follow
through, and that's
something I've learned.
If that's not how you feel, then
make yourself feel that way.
Because if I'm not wanting
to follow through on an idea,
I have to ask myself why
am I procrastinating on it.
And it's just like,
oh, because I'm not
that passionate about it.
So I think, for me,
that's the main thing--
is to just keep finding ways to
stay excited about what you're
working on.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Yeah, thank you.
This feels like a
weird city hall.
NATHAN BARNES: It's
just begun actually.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: No,
we are building the road.
I am building the shooting
range next to the playground.
I'm just kidding.
All right.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Hi.
AUDIENCE: So on
that same topic, I'm
wondering do you write
your lyrics first then
the music or vise versa?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Well, that changes.
I go through phases.
It's usually lyrics first.
Sometimes I'll come up with
a melody that I really like,
and I'll hate the
lyrics, and then
I'll put lyrics that I
wrote previously to that.
But it's definitely
two different things.
I'll write something,
and either I'll
really like the
lyrics or the melody
and then work from there.
I'll decide what is it
about it that I liked?
Was it the way I was--
was it the words,
or was it the way that
I was saying the words?
AUDIENCE: Do you
have someone that you
collaborate with [INAUDIBLE]?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: No.
I mean, I don't collaborate
that often as far as--
I'm kind of bad about
that with songwriting.
And if I do I just have to--
a lot of the times just
give a song to someone else
and leave them alone with it.
I definitely can't watch while
someone else tears it apart.
You know, it's hard
to be open minded.
Once you hear
someone else's ideas,
it's hard to immediately
not just be like, I hate it.
[LAUGHTER]
It's not my idea.
You have to actually try to see
what could be good about it,
you know, just because
it's someone else's idea.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Yeah, you're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Thanks again for
performing this afternoon.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
you've had like a whole life
and career in the
music industry,
and you started out of
doing it on corners at shows
and meeting back
with the family.
You've seen a lot of the music
industry change over the years
as well.
And I'm wondering
if you could share
if you have any sort of
gripes with where the music
industry is today, where
you might see improvements
in the future, or
kind of what you'd
like to see in the future
for the music industry?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Interesting.
Yeah, it's weird.
It's kind of like I don't really
have, like, an idea to fix it,
but you can see
what's happening.
And it's been happening
for most of my life for me.
I can look back to music being
free when I was 10, 11, 12,
and remembering, like,
Napster and all this stuff,
and seeing that even as--
kind of watching that happen
and watching people that
used to make money
doing something--
have people not really want
to invest in it anymore.
And I guess that's
something that I've
kind of seen the way things have
changed, and it's just not--
I don't know.
But I didn't really see the way
things were at the same time
too, so it's an interesting--
I'm really curious
to see where it goes,
but I have no idea of how
I could even imagine that.
Because who knows what's
going to keep changing?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Yeah, no.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'm looking for
advice on how not to lose songs.
So specifically,
imagine you're in love.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: OK.
AUDIENCE: And you write a love
song, and it's a great song,
and then you break up.
What do you do with
that love song that
reminds you of that person?
Do you lose it, or
do you have a way
of owning it, and taking
it back, and making
it yours again?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Oh, yeah.
You just keep singing
it, and you definitely
apply it to something else.
I don't know.
I mean, give it some
time if you have to.
But I mean, especially if you
really like the song, then just
be like, hey, you know what?
The one cool thing I got out
of this was this rad song.
Look at it that way instead
of thinking about her
or whatever--
whoever it is.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any songs like that?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Yeah, definitely.
I mean, I am kind of a
relationship writer too,
so it's--
I definitely write about every
relationship that I've been in,
and then eventually it goes
back to when I was a teenager.
So there's a lot
of teenage breakups
that I still end
up singing about,
and I think that's
ridiculous that this
is part of my life and career.
But it's like,
hey, at least I got
the part of my life and career
out of this relationship.
So cool.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Thank you, guys.
NATHAN BARNES: How do you feel?
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Do you want more music?
NATHAN BARNES:
Feel like playing--
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
I could do more music.
NATHAN BARNES: Yeah.
Do you have some
time for some music?
That would be lovely.
[APPLAUSE]
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: All right.
NATHAN BARNES: Thank you.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Oh, yeah.
Thank you.
Awesome.
[MUSIC - "SAFE 2 CONNECT 2"]
[APPLAUSE]
[WHISTLES]
Do you want more, do you think?
NATHAN BARNES: Yeah,
whatever's good by you.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
I'll do-- yeah.
Cool, I'll do, like,
one more, then you guys
can get back to your life
unless you would just normally
be sitting here like this--
would you all be facing
this direction usually?
AUDIENCE: We're here all day.
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: OK, cool.
Well, thanks for letting
me sit in front of you.
I appreciate it.
[MUSIC - "WISH YOU COULD SEE ME
NOW"]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
NATHAN BARNES: Thanks to you.
[WHISTLES]
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Thank you.
NATHAN BARNES: Thank you so
much to everyone for being here
and supporting
this wonderful day,
and hopefully this
is first of many.
And of course, many
thanks to Jessica
for finding time in between--
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Thank you.
NATHAN BARNES: --tours,
and shows, and driving,
and life to come
stop by with us, so--
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD: Yes.
NATHAN BARNES: --another round
of applause for Jessica--
JESSICA LEA MAYFIELD:
Thanks for having me.
NATHAN BARNES: --in
all her legendness.
[APPLAUSE]